The joe rogan experience.
My brother,
her brother,
I hope she covers all that shit out with a big Gucci Mane.
Ice Cream cone.
Have you seen that?
Yeah.
Gucci Mane put an ice cream color his face.
Well,
what's his name?
Uh,
and paper.
Pull up the picture.
She made ice cream called baby big baby bird mans a oil.
Well,
oil drill on his oil drilling oil.
It's real going tattooed on his side.
It was he does he really?
Yes ma'am.
He's got giant stars over his head to write insane.
Do you know,
just tattooed his fucking head?
Jason Ellis,
he put a giant dam,
got lightning bolts.
Maybe my ass can be on fire.
Gucci Mane is crazy.
Look at him.
He put an ice cream cone on his face.
It says burr.
You see it?
You see it on the cone.
Be Our,
our,
our and the Tattoo guy.
I was like,
okay,
call it ice.
Matt,
could you,
um,
I want,
I'm going to have to get you to request this on video and then I need you to
get,
I need you to write this down.
Come on,
man.
Just tattoo it.
I ain't gonna change my mind,
but a pecan on my face,
man.
Yo Dog.
Don't be giving me no vanilla ice cream.
I Hate Vanilla.
I want a cone of good one.
Like a waffle type motherfucker.
Them delicious cones with the upper level that is like styrofoam,
like
ice cream.
But he's got other shit on his face because yeah,
like writing on his face to
face is wrong.
You see what it says under his eye.
Can you read my pissed yes.
Things on his eye under design or those are tattoos to all my God.
It looks like it's under his,
I said something.
What the fuck?
Bop or some shit.
What does that like?
I see.
What does it say?
1000 vague.
I don't know.
It's hard to say.
10 Times 10 with the s on the
other side.
He has it looks like a dove or something.
Well,
yeah,
that,
that dude is probably irrational.
Gucci.
I don't know anybody today and I'm just,
so I'm out of the loop.
I'm pretty out of it.
I know stuff that like that because it's in the news and I know,
um,
mostly the music I grew up on.
I'm not aware of a lot of the new Shit Gucci Mane.
I know because you know,
like a son to me.
But that's it.
There's so much music that was been been made.
And when you think about the fact that from 1960 whatever to today,
you know,
you want to go crazy,
you want to go Robert Johnson,
you can listen to some shit recorded in the 30s and forties.
Right?
Yeah.
But think about that till today.
What a gigantic pile of music that,
oh,
there's so much out there.
What a body of work,
all the different musicians in the 60s,
the 70s,
the fit.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
There's so much music.
It's like to come up with new stuff.
It's like to really get me into it.
It has to be like the black keys spent just crazy amounts of money.
Like they blow through all nine cars and shit.
Yeah.
Like he blew through a lot of it.
He was on that broke,
um,
special that the air,
and he was just like,
somebody pulled up,
you know,
in like a Ferrari.
You're like,
yeah,
that's just hot.
I got to top that shit.
So then he would go like the day,
that day I got the land by what the brains blown out man.
Like just to top each other guys would just buy shit to show off,
you know,
to compete with each other on it.
They say that there's some ungodly number of people.
It's like 80% of all NFL players are broke and in bankruptcy within two years of
retiring.
It's,
it's incredible.
I mean,
you know,
the older I get,
the more I understand the younger guys having no like 0 million cents and also
zero Fike financial Iq.
Like they don't know no 21,
they're like,
here's the $3 million.
And they're like,
Ooh,
yeah,
it's good.
This part is 22.
Yeah.
I imagine it's crazy,
but it's crazier when they're like,
he played 10,
12,
16 years like Iverson and he's blown through like $200 million in your lives in
broke now.
Yes.
And how old is he now?
He's 37 something like that.
His body's not working right anymore.
Oh,
he's the head of the MBA.
Yeah.
And he's,
and he's trying to play in,
but he's running through well into nine figures,
you know.
Wow.
I mean,
I,
you know,
and that's,
that's,
you know,
you have to consider,
he made a lot of endorsements.
So nine figures,
nine figures to make seven figures.
Yeah.
Girls would be like,
wow,
he makes seven figures.
It's like,
can make nine,
nine a Bluetooth at all.
Yeah.
That shit crazy,
man.
Woopsies that's crazy.
That try really hard.
It's so much.
They,
they interviewed one uh,
defensive,
like a guy on the,
on the,
the special on the,
the broke thing.
And he was like,
I don't know why man.
But he was like,
everybody had a car wash.
He's,
we all had a fucking carwash man.
That shit.
That shit did not last.
Like we all spent money on a car.
We bought a carwash.
Yeah,
man,
you ain't got your own carwash.
Ah.
And Bart Scott had the bay,
he was like,
you buy shit is unnecessary.
He's not broke at all and he's still playing and he's like,
I'm smarter with my money.
But he's like,
you know,
everybody's a stupid purchase.
I bought a coat,
I think it was made a wolf.
Okay.
And I
was like,
I wore that shoe once and it was like $35,000
dude,
I got to tell you Diaz,
first of all,
he got stopped in three different airports by like eight different people this
weekend.
Oh.
By throngs of fans who are saying fans,
TSA
at the airport.
And they want to check out her,
his balls for weed.
He,
first of all,
my God,
that is his tolerance is it's under dunning.
Dude,
I took a quarter of a bite of an edible.
You're brave quarter.
Yeah,
I mean,
the very end of it and 30 minutes later I was just out of my mind.
my eyes weren't even open and I could tell people were looking at me like,
they were like,
yeah,
when you're like,
I'm not hiding this,
this is bad.
And he ate of that.
He ate an entire one like that.
And then he's like saying ridiculous shit like shit that I,
I feel like I get arrested for thinking it like I,
I don't,
I can't play it back in my head.
I was like,
dude,
shut the fuck.
Is he saying I cannot,
I really can't say the main thing that he was,
I can't,
it would be,
it was,
it's not okay to say [inaudible] have to do with ethnic groups,
racial things.
I'll say this one in particular is awful.
It's so awful.
Like I came to spin it.
I can't spend a joke,
but you know,
I have a,
and this is one of the things that I've been on about lately.
I have a real problem when people get upset at people that say shit that they
don't really mean,
but that's awful,
but hilarious.
Yeah,
I agree.
Because like look how hard we're laughing.
No,
yeah,
look at the picture you guys.
Yeah.
I don't even know what he said.
I don't even know what he said to you.
And I'm already laughing,
just crazy thinking about all the shit he said to me in the path.
Of course.
Well,
he,
he's going off about this thing.
I'm standing there,
I look like I'm gonna puke because I'm laughing so hard because this is in the
airport and he's around people.
He has no sense of,
of flies,
blah,
blah.
Shut up dude.
He doesn't give a fuck.
And I've,
I have tears people look at and then he's like Tsa and uh,
this guy,
I look in,
the uniform,
looks over and he's like,
you got to look at this guy.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm all fucked up.
Like don't bring attention to me right now.
And then that guy,
he's like,
Hey Joe,
as my big fan,
I'm like,
are you fucking kidding me right now?
I turn around and walk away.
I was like,
I'm leaving.
It's too high for this.
I walked away,
I leave him.
I'm like,
I don't want any part of the shit.
And I go,
I buy a magazine that I leave at the counter.
That's how high.
I'm not like,
I want to get this magazine.
And then I walk away from it and I remember like 30 minutes later before we
board and I go back and it's sitting there and I go,
that's my magazine.
And Lady's like,
okay.
And I go,
I paid for it already.
And she was like,
okay,
like go ahead and take that if you went out of my mind.
But then,
then we walk by,
we go and a guy,
a fucking pilot comes by,
you know,
they have like,
they're,
they're always have that double look luggage thing right there.
One bag on top of the other,
the pilot bag.
He fucking walks by us and he's like,
Hey Joey Diaz.
And I'm like,
are you serious right now?
And he's like,
it's my airport.
Everybody calls me this airport.
I'm like,
really?
He's my airport.
And then Oregon,
this was in Burbank,
Burbank airport.
We then get stopped in,
we'd land in Sacramento and people stop them for pictures.
Then the baggage handler,
uh,
stops him,
asked him like a hundred weeks.
I hate these fucking questions guys.
Ask Way too many questions.
No.
Okay.
So we,
we leave there.
Well,
he's super high.
Can't off just having conversations with people.
Then a family stops him.
A lady with kids stops him for a picture.
They all take a picture together like it was nonstop.
The best was that,
oh this is the best part.
So I take the quarter bite right and I'm completely fucking out of my mind.
He eats an entire one.
We sit down on the plane and he starts talking to me.
I'm like,
shut up man.
Shut the fuck up.
I cannot listen to you right now cause I'm like shaking.
Like I'm like,
I got,
he told him to shut up cause you're laughing.
Yes,
yes.
I'm like,
I can't hear you talk.
Shut up.
And he's like,
he's like,
he like looked around,
he was like anyways and he opens up a second one,
eats the sec and to have the thing I have a quarter bite of,
so he's on eight doses of why I'm on
and I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
So we go through this flight and every time he looks at me,
like I said,
he goes,
oh,
I like to shop for the dog and story.
No,
he gives Dunkin a cookie and then he calls him an hour and a half later.
It goes,
welcome to my world motherfucker.
Dude,
ow,
ow.
We land,
we land I and M as we're landing.
And I was like,
man,
I go dude,
I was,
I was pretty fucked up man.
And he goes and I look at him,
cause all I'm thinking is like,
I can't believe how much more advanced you are.
The me,
you know,
it's like,
like I cannot believe what you mean.
Tolerance.
Why?
It's like,
it's like I can't believe I ran a mile and you just ran 40 miles.
Like that's crazy to me.
And we both finished at the same time and then I go.
So I'm amazed that he's not affected.
I go,
I can't believe how much that fucking we have to go.
I almost had three panic attacks on that flight you got.
I was like,
yes.
It made me so happy
that he was also fucked up.
And I was like,
Carrie still goes down right back in.
I go,
I'm glad it's starting to wear off.
He goes,
not for me.
Fucked up,
right?
Yeah.
His idea of going deep is so much deeper than your idea.
He's breaking world records on a daily basis all the time.
He's at the bottom of the Marianas trench with a shovel and he's like,
there's be a deepest spot.
This is bullshit.
And the first thing he did as we get off that was like,
let's smoke this joint.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
What are you talking about man?
We're not smoking a joint.
I can take a break and he's a maniac breaks.
He's of no Greg Maniac.
Yeah.
Well he just goes through the whole day like that.
And that's where,
you know,
people would step in and say,
well that boy's got a problem.
Yeah.
I'll tell you what he got.
But he doesn't.
Yeah,
he gets for a comedian.
Yeah.
It might be the best way to live life.
Scared on a regular basis.
And in between laughing your Dick off,
scared,
laughing your dick off.
Scared,
laughing you dick off.
Yeah.
He,
um,
uh,
he is,
the funny thing is like,
even his regular cadence,
it's so is out of the norm for other people that you see people react to them.
It's more fun to even watch people like at the restaurant next to us react to
him than it is almost to watch him.
Like he's talking and I see them like,
they're like,
Jesus,
like this is like a fucking,
it's like you brought in a pit bull to have lunch here.
You know what I mean?
They've never seen somebody so intense and animate and saying these crazy
things.
It's like you watch them react to Joey.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
I know what you mean,
man.
He's just,
it's just,
they don't come along that often.
No,
he's a,
it's a rare thing.
I said,
they're there.
They're like,
well,
who's this guy?
Yeah.
You know,
like,
you know guys and you go,
oh,
I get it.
That guy's like a little bit of this guy.
A little bit of that guy's combination of Joey's just like,
what is that?
Where'd that come from?
You want to kill somebody?
You invite him over for dinner?
What?
Oh,
is his logic,
how to get crimes committed correctly.
And then my favorite thing is they'll say something and go,
you know what the fuck I'm saying do I need to just walks away?
Yeah.
We'll end on a strong point.
You want to kill somebody,
you invite him over dinner.
Oh,
walks away.
Great sense of timing.
Yeah.
Amazing.
It's,
it's a standup timing that he uses like in everyday life or your life.
It's never doing an act because his act as his life and his life as his act.
Yeah.
The way he talks his,
his act.
Totally.
That's like the best you could ever hope for.
The best you could ever hope for is like a merging of you,
of your ability to be you offstage and onstage.
Yeah.
I mean,
I mean look at like who everybody or a lot of people that say it was like,
you know,
total master comedian basically talks in his voice,
like Chapelle walks up and he's like tells you about his day.
Yeah.
And that's kind of like the highest form,
right,
of being a comment.
Cause you're like,
I'm just going to,
this isn't even a thing.
I'm just talking to you.
Yeah.
And like Diaz is like a version of that where like he's just being Diaz.
We know who uh,
was.
Uh,
like I,
I talk,
I tell the story now on stage.
The guy who used to drive us,
oh my God to the airport.
It was our driver,
like a regular guy because we were,
we go to the airport so often we use this,
you know,
without like a cheaper car service,
it's easier than dealing with like driving and parking.
Right.
And like he was,
you know,
it was like a cheap ride,
basically older guy and I'm like all white hair and was really professional.
And then like after like 10 rides,
one of those things where like,
you know,
when somebody like Mr Rogue and Mr and you finally go,
you can call me Joe.
It was like that kind of thing where I was like,
it's Tom,
he's like this,
Tom and I,
I'm like,
yeah.
He's like,
cool.
Hey Man,
let me ask you something.
Like,
everything changed.
As soon as I said,
you don't have to be professional with me.
And he goes,
uh,
he goes,
can I ask you something?
And I was like,
yeah.
And he goes,
do you smoke weed?
And I was like,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
I guess.
Yeah.
And he's like,
do you wanna smoke some now?
I was like,
really,
like five in the morning.
And I was like,
I was like,
yeah.
All right.
And then you said,
yeah,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Driver.
Yeah,
that's exactly what my head comfortable with you in my life.
And then he goes,
he starts smoking and then he goes,
uh,
I can't drive unless I'm fucked up.
That's a quo.
[inaudible]
and then Judd Apatow,
I swear to God,
he's like Seventies.
And then he goes,
and then he's like this morning like this particularly,
it is early.
He drives fast.
He's like one of these,
I've been driving 50 years now.
Like,
we've got to take this street.
And I was like,
you know,
I was basically like,
keep it together man.
And he was like,
he was like,
I've been up since,
you know,
three.
And then I'm like,
Shit.
I started asking him,
I'm like,
have you done other drugs?
He's like,
aw,
buddy buddy.
Like I've done it all.
And I was like,
really?
He's like coke,
heroin.
He's like,
there's nothing like smoking rocks,
swear to God.
And he is flying through El Barrio through the old neighborhood.
So this is an El Salvadorian neighborhoods and every like we're going through
lights and he's like,
look at that little brown one right there.
He was married to a Peruvian and then he had like an El Salvadorian girlfriend.
He's like,
I love these little brown ones at oh one on the side.
Yeah.
Well,
and yet he has like five girlfriends and they're all like 20 20th
we drive to the get out and be like,
that's where I used to buy my crap.
This neighborhood's good stuff.
[inaudible] swear to God.
So we're in the,
we're driving around and I go,
uh,
I go,
oh,
what?
Can I ask you something now that we're friends,
I guess,
you know,
he's like,
yeah,
it's true.
And I was like,
what's it like to smoke crack?
And he goes,
oh man.
He's like,
what I like to do and when I smoked crack is like,
I'll just sit in my apartment where it stop,
stop,
don't say anything.
Did he say porn?
He watches porn.
No,
no.
I'm sorry.
He goes,
uh,
I like to,
I like to look through the people and I look around at what the fuck's out.
And I think I see all this shit.
I think about what's going to happen next.
I see people walking by and I just kind of fucking freak out,
you know?
And
I was like,
this sounds terrible,
man.
He was like,
as part of the rush,
that's the rush.
You know what the law happen.
You will
come get you.
That's his rush to stop you because everybody says,
everybody that I've ever talked to him and smoked crack says they watch porn.
Oh,
I invited this girl over when we fuck like animal like you would have.
Yeah,
he did say that.
Sorry.
Sorry,
I can't say his last name.
I know his last name.
Henry the eighth.
So the best is,
uh,
like in this sounds like,
I swear this is exactly how it goes.
I go,
so do you still do that?
Shit goes,
ah Nah man,
Nah,
no,
no.
He goes,
well,
you know,
every once in a while,
but you know what they say if you do something every once in a while,
it's not that bad for you.
And I go,
I think they mean that about like pizza,
chocolate.
And he's like,
swear to God.
Every once in a while we'll,
do you remember when the mayor of Washington DC got caught smoking Marion?
Yeah.
With an FBI agent in the fucking hotel room or an informant.
She was being a prostitute.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You remember that Shit.
He was smoking crack and running the nation's capitol.
And then when they asked people about it,
the greatest thing was after he got caught,
this guy,
I remember this guy on TV,
they say,
what do you think about the mayor getting caught smoking?
Greg goes,
man,
everybody's a molo cracking,
but now and then every now he said,
everybody smoke a little crack every now and then.
This guy was on TV.
He's like,
come on man,
stop playing.
You're being reduced.
Why you stopped playing?
Who doesn't?
Who doesn't vote crack?
Hey by smoked some great mental now and then
that reminds me of the first time I bought drugs.
The first time I ever bought drugs.
Tell me what you remember.
You remember the first time you were married?
He told me that you had a story.
I met the first time it about drugs.
I was in high school and I went to a small high school so I was trying to be
like,
not make a thing to ask about it at first.
You know,
cause you don't want it to get around and like be a cause.
So you were curious?
Yeah,
I wanted to try stuff but I didn't know who to ask because if you ask like at a
small school you're like,
I could blow up real fast.
Right.
That's how guys would traveling.
So my friend Steve had just transferred from like the big high school,
like from a high school with like 5,000 kids.
And so it was like a weekend and I was like,
let's get a sack.
And I think we had just seen menace to society and we were like,
Yo,
what's up?
Like we were trying to tell her it'd be like hardcore guys.
I'm like pulling the hat to the side and be like,
he's do this.
And did you wear your hat to the side?
No,
but I think,
you know,
a lot of like throwing swag and shit and like,
hey,
let's get a sack.
You getting your blackness on?
Definitely feeling it.
14 like what's up dude?
This shit.
I got your back right.
And making shit up.
Little too white,
right?
Yeah.
And so comfortable with your existence.
Totally.
And then,
uh,
he's like,
I'll hook,
I know the guy.
So this is like a Saturday night.
This like long drink,
like old school,
Seventies Cadillac pulls up and like,
he's like,
that's the dude and this guy rolls the window down.
He's like,
Yo,
getting it back.
And I was like,
all right,
cool.
We get in the back if the thinking like that's where it goes down.
And,
uh,
Steve's like,
Yo,
this is white Pete.
And I was like,
what's up Wipe Pete?
Like,
and then he was called White Pete cause they needed to give him a distinction
for his name because he was the only white guy that ran with his crew.
Right.
And he was like,
we didn't have driver's licenses.
So he was like,
exactly what we at that moment where we want it to be in a couple of years.
Like he had like the whole unit,
like the oversized white tea and like,
you know,
gold chain.
Yeah.
And fucking like fate.
And he was like,
what's up?
I'm white people.
He talked like snoop Dogg almost.
Oh right.
And so we were like,
all right.
And I thought,
he's like,
so we're going to go get it now.
I was like,
go get what?
Like I thought we were just doing this in the car,
wouldn't go get that sac man.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
So we started driving,
we go 30 minutes in a car,
we go to the next town over,
which is Fort Pierce,
which is definitely a shittier place.
Right.
So we're driving through Fort Pierce and we go from a main street to like single
lane highways.
You know,
in Florida there's like,
Oh yeah,
we're on a busy,
then we go to a single lane that has like canals on each side.
Ooh.
Yeah.
And we're driving and then we go from that to a dirt road and then the dirt road
off of that dirt road.
Like we're driving down with like,
this is some forensic files,
Shit.
Like we're going to end up on,
there's a lot of woods.
Yeah.
A lot of brush,
uh,
groves,
that kind of shit.
And I was like,
fuck man.
And at this point,
like I'm thinking about like menace to society and I'm like,
I want to be in that right now.
But I'm feeling like,
ah,
feeling really white,
my like really scared and so,
and now it's night and it,
you know,
it's like,
cause he came over in the evening already,
so now it's pitch black outside and we're on a dirt road off of a dirt road.
Like you can scream,
there's nobody gonna hear Shit.
And on the dirt road up gravel path.
I see a light and the light is from a trailer because we pull up to the trailer
and we get out and it's me,
Steve and white Pete.
And we knock on the door,
that trailer and this dude opens the door and he has his black guy that has like
six dreadlocks,
like you know,
each dreadlock is like a size of like a king size snickers bar.
And he's got six snicker bars coming out of his hair and why?
He's like,
what's up Pat Pat?
And he's like,
what's up White Pete?
And they give each other a hug.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
Now this really is like totally menace to society shit.
Right?
But I'm told,
so trying to be cool about it,
like,
so trying to be cool about it.
And then,
uh,
he's like these white boys looking for a sack and he's like,
yeah,
we could do that.
So we go on.
So the mind,
you were looking for $20 and we drove.
And how long has it taken?
This is from his point.
It's like we're already 30 miles southwest of the city.
We started,
would you just say like,
nevermind after 10 miles
white peaches sell to you,
why does he have to take you on the trip to the God's house?
I would,
these are all questions I have,
but don't have the balls to ask.
Like I,
I'm in my mind,
I'm like,
ah,
like I'm 14,
15 and I'm not saying it shift to this dude.
Right.
I'm cool.
What's up?
Let's get a sack.
Right.
We'll try me.
So we go into his trailer and he's like,
all right,
we're going to get to do that sec.
Uh,
we back in 10 minutes.
I was like,
who would be back in 10 minutes?
He's like,
we will be you stay here and watch my place.
And I was like,
what?
Like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Is what I'm thinking?
But then I just go like,
yeah,
cool.
Totally.
You're in his trailer.
And he's like,
watch it for me.
And I'm like,
oh no.
Like I'm feeling like that,
like real fear.
But I go,
yeah,
no problem man.
Like I watched people's houses all the time,
like it totally fucking terrified.
And then he goes like the,
you walk in the trailer,
you're in the living room because that's the way to train leaders,
right?
You walk into it as a bedroom to the right.
He's like waiting here on the bad.
He's like,
it was a 45 and a 12 gauge and he goes,
anybody comes in my,
in my house,
you shoot him.
And I was like,
right.
And then he's like a Sephora,
my Mama,
my mama comes home,
don't shoot her.
And I was like,
got it and accept.
I kept trying to be cool about it and I was like,
yeah,
like that's what's up.
I know,
I know what you're saying man.
Look at that sac.
Totally like trying to be like,
he was like,
all right.
They walk out,
they leave me in his trailer with two guns and a fucking message to not to shoot
everybody but his mother and I just sit there and I watch the MTV video music
awards and the whole time,
like every show that comes,
I just am rocking and I'm actually hoping that it's an intruder versus his mom
because I feel like if it's his mom,
she might accidentally shoot her.
How is she going to react to my explanation?
Like pep had just told me to wait here.
Well he's getting some weed for me,
but I'm,
that's what I'm supposed to shoot everybody,
but you,
are you cool with that?
And she's like,
oh yeah,
that happens.
All thought like,
how are you going to react to this?
So I fuck,
I mean,
I'm having a panic attack.
We finally,
they come back,
I get back in with a white Pete,
he drives us back and I'm sitting there,
I'm like,
what the fuck dude,
that was the worst shit ever.
Like I'm fucking terrified.
And he's like,
yeah,
him and Pat,
Pat,
Steven,
pat became like best friends.
So they became like super close.
Like that was like his guy he would go to and I'd be like,
no dude,
I don't want to hang out with pat pat at all.
And like six months later when Steve got his license,
we went and he was like,
you want to get some weed today?
I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
So where we go,
we go to fort peers,
pull it to pat Pat's and I'm like,
God dammit Mike.
She remembered how to get there.
He did.
Steve had started going there all the time.
Oh my God.
We pulled up to his trailer this time he gets out now this time I'm like,
well,
they're friends,
so this is probably gonna be a much quicker thing.
He comes out,
he jumps in the back and he's like,
all right,
let's roll.
And I was like,
ah,
no,
like fuck.
And look for a sack again.
Like I thought you just have this.
So this time we went to this,
but these are the things [inaudible] scared the shit out of me the first time.
But that second time he saved our life actually because we went from his trailer
the second time where he jumped in the back,
went to Avenue d,
which is the fucking shitty street in Fort Pierce.
Like if you're going to like every city,
you know you have like,
I dunno whatever city you're in there like that's ever seen.
Have you been to the street where you see open drug dealing where there's not
even some type of facades?
Angeles had been down a street where there's like,
there's no pretense about it.
There's just like Los Angeles,
which part of filming?
Fear factor.
We were actually filming the playboy playmate addition of fear factor downtown
area and yeah,
we were watching people sell drugs,
smoke crack right there.
We were in a crane and we're like,
oh look,
they're smoking crack.
And the girls like,
oh my God,
they are smoking crack and like this is ridiculous.
No one's protecting us.
We're up here on a crane.
That was exactly like this where we pulled up in,
in Steve's car and the windows come down and we just get surrounded.
Like the car got surrounded by six guys and they reached in their jackets and
they go at this one guy who is,
you all look familiar and this other guy goes,
yeah,
y'all are real familiar.
Y'All ever been here before and that when you,
when somebody says that you looked familiar I've with any before,
how would you answer that?
I just say uh,
nope.
Nope.
Right at exactly at that moment I got no,
and Steve at the exact same it goes yup,
a man and then they're like,
see,
I told you man,
y'all look like the white boys.
They've been snatching bags around here that was like,
ah,
fuck.
Like you look like the white boys that haven't taken bags from guys.
I'm like,
no dude,
that's not us.
And Steve's like,
but we have been here before.
I'm like,
will you shut the fuck up?
Hackpad is in the back of like,
hold on.
He gets out and like walks up,
talks to all of them,
like,
uh,
you know,
like he's the ambassador,
right?
And like,
I don't know what the fuck you like.
I own these guys there with me like fucking,
and they totally let us go,
but without,
without him we would have been fucked.
What's that noise?
What is that noise?
That's not mine.
It's my
pat pat.
Pat,
pat.
Pat.
Pat is still,
I don't know what happened to Pat,
pat and white Pete who knows things?
Probably not good things,
man.
You should Facebook.
Um,
can you fix book pat?
Pat.
That would be the next person that makes up a fake Twitter accounts of real fee.
That was,
I had real fear.
Oh yeah.
You're like,
for good fucking reason.
Oh.
Like when you feel your stomach dropping your like,
what's going to happen right now?
Oh my God.
Yeah.